situación de caos en manaos donde las
últimas horas han muerto decenas de
pacientes asfixiados los relatos de los
médicos son escalofriantes algunos
incluso han tenido quería animar a los
pacientes en el suelo porque no quedan
camas libres en los hospitales lo peor
de todo es que la empresa que forme de
oxígeno a los hospitales públicos había
avisado al gobierno central la semana
pasada de que no podría seguir
abasteciendo debido a la alta demanda y
que podría cundir el pánico aún así nada
se ha hecho y ahora la justicia federal
ha determinado el traslado y al menos
235 pacientes graves a hospitales de
otros estados o hemos visto los primeros
llegando había hoy un estado de la
región del noroeste
en este escenario caótico el presidente
del país
jair bolsonaro ha dicho que su gobierno
ha hecho todo lo que podía y ha
confirmado que la fecha de inicio de la
vacunación podría retrasarse desde ayer
había un avión preparado para ir hasta
la india y recoger 2 millones de dosis
de vacuna de la empresa astra zéneca sin
embargo por razón
políticas este viaje se ha y
no hay una fecha definida para empezar
la vacunación lo que podría salvar un
país que ya contabiliza 207 mil muertos
hoy el alcalde de manaos ha culpado a
bolsonaro de ser responsable directo de
estas muertes y mientras tanto el
ministro de sanidad ha pedido al
instituto butantán de sao paulo que
entregue las 6 millones de dosis de
vacuna que habían sido producidas por el
gobernador de san pablo para la
población de su estado